haben sie das vertrauen nach ihrer zeit
in der politik dass sie sagen würden
diese politik aktuell die aktuelle
regierung wird diese probleme jetzt
lösen also ich habe nicht das gefühl
wenn ich mir anschaue was im kabinett
passiert und also frau carlitscheck
liegt nach einem jahr vor
was die expertin über die sicherheit in
den schulen sagen nach einem jahr
ich glaube dass sich viele eltern fragen
hey das wussten wir doch alles schon
sehr viel er es hätte sehr viel eher auf
dem tisch liegen müssen
das zutrauen habe ich nicht glaube wir
brauchen da wirklich eine veränderung
gebrauchen wirklich leute hin zu packen
wollen und die auch mit der mit dem
alltag und mit der realität von kindern
und familien und von menschen die kleine
läden haben von künstlerinnen auch
tatsächlich zu tun